foreign
okay guys let's go back to high school
does anyone remember that feeling of
walking into the school cafeteria with
your tray in your hand and not knowing
where to sit
yeah I see some people nodding okay cool
you might have sat alone or perhaps more
likely
you looked for someone who felt familiar
you sat with a group of people that
reminded you of you and even today when
deciding where to sit
how many of you chose to sit next to
someone who looked or felt different
from you
I would bet that not many of you did
that
I guess not much changes in some
situations whether you're 17 or you're
70.
we've all likely felt this tendency to
gravitate towards people who look think
and act like us it's comfortable but it
can also be harmful
because this polarization that we face
today isn't just about believing that
the other side is factually wrong
we are beginning to see the other side
as malevolent beings with a hateful and
hidden agenda and you can see this you
can see this in the screaming cable news
pundits
the politicians who vote down bills just
because they come from the other side of
the aisle
the hate groups that violently attack
people who are different from themselves
when I see these things as a teenager I
just feel so sad so angry and so scared
of this world that I'm soon going to be
entering as an adult
but there's something that I've found in
having conversations with my peers that
I think can be a path forward from all
of this an approach that focuses on
conversations with the intent to listen
and learn not to win and not to agree
so I'm a 17 year old from Naperville
Illinois
in the summer before my sophomore year
of high school I attended the ACLU
National advocacy institute's high
school program in Washington DC during
this program I had the chance to take
part in a lot of different political
discussions and I remember this one
conversation about the death penalty in
particular
so back then I wholeheartedly believed
in this meaning of an eye for an eye
that punishment should be equal to the
offense because you know that's what I
grew up hearing and so I argued the same
I was however met with immediate
opposition
my peers told me that the death penalty
estate sanctuary and murder and that it
reinforces the very Behavior that's
trying to suppress
I tried arguing that the death penalty
the terrorist crime but then my peers
told me that in states without the death
penalty the murder rate is actually
significantly lower
I then tried arguing that the death
penalty brings closure for the victims
families
only to be told that the length between
sentencing and execution actually puts
the victims families through an
agonizing weight period
so by this point I realized that this
debate
not going all that great for me
I realized that my perspective was
inherited and this is when I decided to
stop trying to win the debate and
instead
I just listened
and in the months that followed I took
it upon myself to learn more
I poured over articles and data from
sources ranging from the more liberal
like the Brennan Center for justice to
the more conservative like the Heritage
Foundation
and I learned that historically
capital punishment has been
disproportionately applied to people of
color
and that that penalty isn't actually
proven to deter crime
slowly my thinking changed
and this change only happened because I
engaged with people who had opposing
perspectives you know it's it's hard to
break out of your own Echo chamber
because most of the time we don't
realize that we're even in one until
we're out of it but this was my first
step
so shortly after this experience I
started a non-partisan initiative called
project heal to encourage and Empower
high school students to become
politically involved
we discuss a lot of different issues
like education Equity voter suppression
racial Justice and I've seen some
amazing things happen when people just
talk to one another
understanding and accepting of our
differences
I actually remember this one
conversation in this number of 2020.
there was a boy and a girl who were
debating the Merit of the black lives
matter movement and I remember being
afraid that their conversation would
evolve into an argument
but it didn't
instead I learned that the girl who was
black came from a family that had been
through a couple of rough instances with
the police
and the boy who was the son of a cop
came from an upbringing in which BLM was
labeled as a movement in defiance of the
police
later on I was surprised to learn that
though they still didn't agree the boy
and the girl learned something about the
other that they didn't know before and
more than that they appreciated how it
shaped the other person's unique
perspective and this was only possible
because they didn't delve into a
shouting match or call each other
disrespectful names and for me this was
an aha moment
I realized that we shouldn't back away
from discussing polarizing issues even
if it's with people who disagree with us
sure it's uncomfortable and yeah I'd
probably agree that we don't change our
minds most of the time
but we can better understand opposing
perspectives which can help us to better
advocate for our own beliefs and maybe
just maybe it even allows us to reach a
compromise when the situation demands it
so I think the question remains how can
we create space for this kind of
bipartisan discourse
well I think the first step is finding a
community
when I think back to my experience in
the ACLU I think the reason we were able
to have that civil discourse was because
we recognize that we were a part of a
greater cause
and because my peers knew me not just as
an opposing voice but as Shreya
their peer their fellow teen activist
and their friend
and when we are able to recognize what
unites us it becomes so much easier to
have conversations about what divides us
and most Americans actually validate
what I've seen in practice
while 77 of American voters pulled
before the 2020 presidential election
said that they had just a few or no
close friends who supported the other
side's candidate
79 of Americans agree that creating
opportunities for bipartisan civil
discourse would be effective in reducing
divisions 79 that's pretty incredible if
you ask me
we all have Affinity groups that we can
join maybe it's a friend group at your
place of work a book club at the local
library or the PTA at your kid's school
whatever this group is
try to have an uncomfortable
conversation with them at least once a
week now okay what exactly constitutes
as uncomfortable
I would say that's really up for you to
decide
it can be about politics sure
or it can be about a different topic
entirely like religion or identity
whatever this topic may be just talk
about something that's uncomfortable
unconventional and meaningful to you
and most importantly do it with the
intent to listen and learn not to win
and not to agree
and you know another tip make sure to
stay off of your phone for this
conversation
yeah
you know as someone who's pretty much
obsessed with Tick Tock I completely
understand how addicting social media
can be believe me
but by discussing polarizing issues
online we lose that person-to-person
connection that really humanizes
opposing perspectives
that allows us to see and empathize with
one another
because by having these conversations
you will gain insight into people who
think differently than you do and who
knows maybe you'll convince someone of a
belief that you hold dearly or maybe
you'll even be moved to reconsider your
own viewpoint
in a month's time I'm going to be
graduating from high school thank you
thank you
over the past four years I've learned a
lot about creating positive discourse
but I'm still scared of this
polarization
this growing unwillingness to view those
who politically disagree with us as
human
honestly it's it's a little overwhelming
to think that I'm soon going to enter
this reality where I'll be confronted
with this division
where I'll be stereotyped and judged by
my ideology my identity and my way of
thinking by people who don't even know
the real me
as a teenager it's a lot
and I know that many of my fellow
chanciers feel the exact same way
and this is precisely why addressing
this polarization crisis is so urgent
and demands action from all of us
just for one moment go back to that high
school cafeteria but this time you sit
down with that other crowd the kids who
didn't look or think like you do
and just imagine what you could have
learned thank you